nginx it's like a gateway that stands
between the internet and your back-end
infrastructure
when you visit a web app the first place
your request will go is to a web server
its job is to look at the requested
resource and determine where to find it
on the server then send it back
as the response in fact if you open up
the network tab in chrome dev tools
right now
you can look at the server header on any
response and there's a good chance it'll
be nginx
it's extremely popular with high traffic
sites because it can handle more than 10
000 simultaneous connections with its
event driven architecture
it's also commonly used as a reverse
proxy where it acts as a traffic light
to distribute the load to multiple
backend servers while also providing
security
and caching for better performance in
most cases it'll be installed on a linux
server with the configuration file being
found in the etc
directory you customize the behavior of
your server by defining directives
a directive is just a key value pair or
if followed by braces it's known as a
context which itself holds more
directives
in the global context we might want to
specify things like a username
and where to save our error logs but
most of your configuration will likely
be done in the http context
now one of the most important roles of
nginx is to serve out static content
like
images and html we can handle that in
the http context where we'll define one
or more servers
each server is distinguished by the port
that it listens to nginx will keep track
of every request to the server
which you can write to an access log the
most important thing though is to tell
the server where to find the raw files
which we do in the location context
now when a user navigates to our domain
it knows where to find the html
on the file system and we might want to
set up a second location
to match any image pattern to the images
directory other common things you might
handle in your server config
include ssl certificates rewrites and
routing to a proxy server when i replace
root with proxy pass
i can point to a completely different
server on the internet what we've
created is a reverse proxy that can
handle caching
anonymity and load balancing this has
been nginx in 100 seconds
hit the like button if you want to see
more short videos like this thanks for
watching
and i will see you in the next one